Hablaré de la compasión y la regla de oro
desde una perspectiva secular e incluso desde una perspectiva en cierto sentido científica.
Someramente intentaré ofrecerles una historia natural
de la compasión y de la regla de oro.
Por momentos usaré un lenguaje más o menos clínico,
así que quizá la charla no les parecerá tan cálida y suave
como las charlas comunes acerca de la compasión.
Quiero advertirles al respecto de esto.
Por eso quiero decir, para empezar, que pienso que la compasión es una gran cosa.
La regla de oro es maravillosa. Soy un gran defensor de ambas.
Y creo que es maravilloso que las religiones del mundo,
los líderes de las religiones del mundo,
estén afirmando la compasión y la regla de oro como principios fundamentales
integrales para sus fes.
Al mismo tiempo, creo que las religiones no merecen llevarse todo el crédito.
Creo que en esto la naturaleza les dio una mano.
Esta noche voy a defender que la compasión y la regla de oro están,
en cierto sentido, incorporadas en la naturaleza humana.
Ok. Pero también voy a defender que
una vez que comprendemos el sentido en el que están incorporadas en la naturaleza humana,
nos damos cuenta de que no basta con simplemente
afirmar la compasión y afirmar la regla de oro.
Hay mucho que hacer después de eso. Ok.
Entonces una breve historia natural; primero de la compasión.
En el principio ya existía la compasión,
y no me refiero a cuando aparecieron por primera vez los seres humanos,
sino incluso desde antes.
Creo que es probable que en el linaje evolutivo humano,
incluso antes de la existencia del homo sapiens,
sentimientos como la compasión, el amor y la simpatía
ya se hubieran ganado un lugar en el acervo genético,
y los biólogos tienen una idea clara de cómo sucedió esto originalmente.
Sucedió mediante un principio conocido como selección de parentesco.
La idea básica de la selección de parentesco es que
si un animal siente compasión por un familiar cercano,
y esta compasión hace que el animal ayude al familiar,
al final la compasión termina ayudando a los genes que subyacen
a la compasión misma.
Desde el punto de vista del biólogo, la compasión es en realidad
una manera en que los genes se ayudan a sí mismos.
Les advertí que esto no iba a ser cálido y suave. Ok.
Ya lo veremos. Aunque espero ponerme un poco más suave.
Para mí, esto no... no me molesta mucho que el
fundamento darwiniano que subyace a la compasión
sea egoísta, o interesado, a nivel genético.
En realidad, lo que considero mala noticia acerca de la selección de parentesco
es que este tipo de compasión solo se manifiesta
naturalmente dentro de la familia.
Esa es la mala noticia. La buena noticia es que la compasión es natural.
La mala noticia es que esta compasión seleccionada por parentesco
está restringida de manera natural a la familia.
Y hay más buenas noticias, provenientes de un momento posterior en la evolución,
un segundo tipo de lógica evolutiva.
Los biólogos la llaman altruismo recíproco.
Aquí la idea básica es que la compasión
nos lleva a hacer el bien por personas que luego harán lo mismo por nosotros.
De nuevo, ya sé que esta no es una noción de la compasión tan inspiradora
como otras que tal vez hayan escuchado en el pasado,
pero desde el punto de vista del biólogo, este tipo de compasión involucrada en el altruismo recíproco
también es interesada.
No es que las personas lo piensen así cuando sienten compasión.
No es un egoísmo consciente, pero para un biólogo esa es la lógica.
Luego uno termina fácilmente ampliando la compasión a amigos y aliados.
Estoy seguro que muchos de ustedes se sienten realmente mal cuando algo terrible
le pasa a un amigo cercano.
Pero si leen en el diario que algo
realmente horrible le sucedió a alguien que no conocen, pues
pueden seguir adelante tranquilamente. Ok.
Así es la naturaleza humana.
Es otra historia con buenas y malas noticias.
Es bueno que la compasión se extendiera más allá de la familia
gracias a este tipo de lógica evolutiva.
Lo malo es que de esto no se deriva por sí misma una compasión universal.
Así que queda trabajo por hacer.
Otro resultado de esta dinámica del altruismo recíproco
que también considero un buena noticia,
es que la manera en que esto se desarrolla en la especie humana
les ha dado a las personas algo así como una apreciación intuitiva de la regla de oro.
Con esto no quiero dar a entender que la regla de oro está inscrita en nuestros genes;
pero podríamos visitar una sociedad de cazadores recolectores
que no haya estado expuesta a ninguna de las más importantes tradiciones religiosas,
ni a la filosofía de la ética,
y si pasáramos cierto tiempo con estas personas
encontraríamos que, básicamente, creen que un buen acto merece otro,
y que las malas acciones deben castigarse.
Y los psicólogos evolucionistas piensan que estas intuiciones tienen una base genética.
Ellos entienden que si uno quiere que lo traten bien,
uno debe tratar bien a los demás.
Y que es bueno tratar bien a otras personas.
Eso está muy cerca de ser una intuición incorporada.
Esas son las buenas noticias. Pero si han estado poniendo atención,
probablemente estarán anticipando que también habrá una mala noticia,
que todavía no llegamos al amor universal,
y eso es cierto, porque a pesar de que una apreciación de la regla de oro es natural,
también es natural imaginar excepciones para la regla de oro. Ok.
Por ejemplo, seguramente ninguno de nosotros desea ir a prisión,
pero todos pensamos que algunas personas deben ir a prisión. ¿Cierto?
Creemos que debemos tratarlas de una manera diferente de la que nos gustaría ser tratados.
Y tenemos razones para eso.
Decimos que hicieron cosas malas que justifican que vayan a prisión.
Nadie extiende la regla de oro de una manera verdaderamente difundida y universal.
Tenemos la capacidad de forjar excepciones
y poner personas en categorías especiales.
Y el problema es que, aunque en el caso de enviar personas a prisión
contamos con un poder judicial imparcial
que determina a quién se excluye de la regla de oro,
en la vida cotidiana tomamos las decisiones acerca de
a quiénes no vamos a tratar con la regla de oro
con una fórmula más expedita y menos precisa,
que básicamente se reduce a si eres mi enemigo, si eres mi rival,
si no eres mi amigo, si no formas parte de mi familia
estaré mucho menos inclinado a aplicarte la regla de oro. Ok.
Todos lo hacemos de una manera u otra,
y es así en todo el mundo.
Lo vemos en Medio Oriente.
Las personas de Gaza lanzan misiles a Israel.
A ellos no les gustaría que les lancen misiles, pero dicen,
"Bueno, los israelíes, o algunos de ellos han hecho cosas
que los colocan en una categoría especial."
A los israelíes no les gustaría que se les impusiera un bloqueo económico,
pero ellos le imponen uno a Gaza y dicen,
"Bueno, los palestinos, o algunos de ellos, se lo han buscado."
Buena parte de los problemas mundiales se deben a estas exclusiones de la regla de oro.
Y es natural hacerlas.
El hecho de que la regla de oro esté de alguna manera incorporada en nosotros
no va a traernos, por sí mismo, el amor universal.
No va a salvar el mundo.
Pero hay una buena noticia que sí podría salvar el mundo.
¿Están al borde de sus asientos?
Espero que así sea porque antes de contarles la buena noticia
tendré que hacer un pequeño rodeo por terreno académico.
Espero mantener su atención con esta promesa de las buenas noticias
que podrían salvar el mundo.
Me refiero al asunto de la aditividad no nula del que algo acaban de escuchar.
Es una breve introducción a la teoría de juegos.
No será doloroso. Ok.
Se trata de juegos de suma nula y juegos de suma no nula.
Si se preguntan cuál tipo de situación
lleva a que las personas se conviertan en amigas y aliadas,
la respuesta técnica es: una situación de suma no nula.
Y si se preguntan cuál tipo de situación
lleva a que las personas definan a otras personas como enemigas,
la respuesta es una situación de suma nula. Ok.
¿Qué significan estos términos?
Básicamente, un juego de suma nula es el tipo de juego al que estamos acostumbrados en los deportes,
en los cuales hay un ganador y un perdedor.
Sus fortunas suman cero. Ok.
En tenis, cada punto es bueno para uno y malo para la otra persona,
o bueno para ella y malo para uno.
De cualquier manera las fortunas suman cero. Ese es un juego de suma nula.
En cambio, cuando jugamos dobles,
la persona del lado de uno
participa en una relación de suma no nula con uno,
porque cada punto es bueno para los dos: ganancia-ganancia;
o malo para los dos: pérdida-pérdida.
Ese es un juego de suma no nula.
En la vida real hay muchos juegos de suma no nula.
En el ámbito económico, por ejemplo, si uno compra algo
eso quiere decir que uno prefiere tener la mercancía que el dinero,
pero el comerciante prefiere tener el dinero que la mercancía.
Los dos sienten que ganan. Ok.
En una guerra, dos aliados están jugando un juego de suma no nula.
Las cosas para ellos serán ganancia-ganancia o pérdida-pérdida.
En la vida real hay muchos juegos de suma no nula.
Entonces podemos básicamente reformular lo que dije antes
acerca de cómo se manifiestan la compasión y la regla de oro,
diciendo simplemente que la compasión fluye naturalmente por canales de suma no nula
en los que las personas se perciben a sí mismas como potencialmente en situaciones de ganar-ganar
con algunos de sus amigos o aliados.
Las manifestaciones de la regla de oro
suceden de manera natural a través de estos canales de suma no nula.
Así que es en redes de aditividad no nula
donde uno esperaría que la compasión y la regla de oro
cumplan mejor su función.
En canales de suma nula uno esperaría algo diferente.
Ok. Ahora ya están listos para las buenas noticias que podrían salvar el mundo.
Aunque ahora debo admitir que también podría no ser así.
ahora que mantuve su atención durante los tres minutos de materia técnica.
Pero podría ser que sí. La buena noticia es que la historia
ha ampliado de manera natural estas redes de aditividad no nula,
estas redes que pueden actuar como canales para la compasión.
Podemos ir atrás hasta la edad de piedra y,
me parece, a partir de la evolución tecnológica, las carreteras, la rueda, la escritura,
muchas tecnologías de transporte y comunicación
han logrado de forma inexorable que más personas
pueden estar en más relaciones de suma no nula
con más y más personas a distancias cada vez mayores. Ok.
Esa es más o menos la historia de la civilización.
Es la razón por la cual la organización social haya crecido desde las villas de los cazadores recolectores
al estado antiguo, al imperio y ahora donde estamos nosotros: en un mundo globalizado.
La historia de la globalización es en buena medida una historia de aditividad no nula.
Probablemente han escuchado el término "interdependencia"
aplicado al mundo moderno. Es simplemente otro nombre para la aditividad no nula.
Si su fortuna es interdependiente con alguien,
usted vive en una relación de suma no nula con esa persona.
En el mundo moderno esto es muy común.
Lo vimos en la reciente crisis económica:
suceden malas cosas en la economía
y son malas para todos en casi todo el mundo.
Y si pasan cosas buenas, son buenas para gran parte del mundo.
Y felizmente puedo decir que creo que realmente contamos con evidencia
de que este tipo de conexión de suma no nula
puede ampliar el radio de acción moral.
Es decir, si pensamos en las actitudes de los estadounidenses
hacia los japoneses durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
las descripciones de los japoneses
en los medios estadounidenses como más o menos subhumanos,
y pensamos en el hecho de que les lanzamos bombas atómicas
sin realmente pensarlo bien,
y lo comparamos con la actitud actual,
creo que en parte se debe a un tipo de interdependencia económica.
Cualquier forma de interdependencia o relación de suma no nula
nos obliga a reconocer la humanidad de las personas.
Y pienso que eso está bien.
El mundo está lleno de dinámicas de suma no nula.
En muchos sentidos los problemas ambientales nos ponen a todos en el mismo barco.
Y existen relaciones de suma no nula de las que las personas no están conscientes.
Por ejemplo, probablemente muchos cristianos estadounidenses
no se piensan a sí mismos como parte de una relación de suma no nula
con musulmanes que están al otro lado del mundo,
pero realmente lo están, porque si estos musulmanes están cada día más contentos
con su lugar en el mundo y sienten que tienen un lugar en el mundo,
eso es bueno para los estadounidenses porque habrá menos terroristas
que amenacen la seguridad de Estados Unidos.
Si cada día se sienten menos contentos, eso será malo para los estadounidenses.
Así que hay abundancia de aditividad no nula.
Y entonces la pregunta es: Si existe tanta aditividad no nula,
¿por qué el mundo no está aún imbuido de amor, paz y comprensión?
La respuesta es complicada. Y quizá merecería otra charla,
pero ciertamente un par de cosas son que,
primero, hay muchas situaciones de suma nula en el mundo.
Y además, a veces las personas no reconocen
la dinámica de suma no nula que hay en el mundo.
Creo que en estas dos áreas
los políticos pueden desempeñar un papel.
Esto no solo tiene que ver con religión.
Creo que los políticos pueden ayudar a fomentar relaciones de suma no nula,
el vínculo económico generalmente es mejor que los bloqueos y otras cosas
por el estilo.
Y los políticos pueden y deben estar conscientes de que
cuando las personas de todo el mundo los observan,
y observan su país,
y captan sus señales
acerca de si están en una relación de suma nula o en una de suma no nula con un país
como, por ejemplo, Estados Unidos, o cualquier otro país,
la psicología humana es tal que ellos usan señales como:
¿Sentimos que se nos está respetando?
Porque, históricamente, si alguien no se siente respetado
probablemente no terminará en una relación de suma no nula,
mutuamente provechosa, con otras personas.
Debemos estar conscientes del tipo de señales que estamos dando.
Y parte de esto pertenece al ámbito del trabajo político.
Si hay algo que puedo alentar a todos a hacer,
a políticos, a líderes religiosos y a nosotros mismos,
sería lo que llamo ampliar la imaginación moral.
Es decir, la capacidad para ponerse en los zapatos de personas
que están en circunstancias muy diferentes.
Esto no es lo mismo que la compasión,
pero conduce a la compasión. Abre los canales para la compasión.
Pero me temo que, aquí, tenemos de nuevo una historia con buenas y malas noticias,
y es que la imaginación moral es parte de la naturaleza humana.
Eso es bueno, pero, de nuevo, tendemos a manifestarlo selectivamente.
Una vez que definimos a alguien como enemigo,
nos cuesta ponernos en sus zapatos, y esto es algo natural.
Tomemos un caso particularmente difícil: un estadounidense
ve en TV a una persona en Irán quemando una bandera de Estados Unidos.
El estadounidense promedio se resistirá
a hacer el ejercicio moral de ponerse en el lugar de esa persona
y rechazará la idea de que tiene mucho en común con esa persona.
Y si les dicen a ellos, pues ellos piensan que Estados Unidos los irrespeta
y que quiere dominarlos, y ellos odian a los Estados Unidos.
¿Alguna vez alguien los irrespetó tanto como para que ustedes
llegaran a odiar a esa persona, aunque fuese brevemente?
Pues ellos rechazarán esa comparación y eso es natural, es humano.
Y, de la misma manera, a la persona en Irán,
cuando se trata de humanizar a un estadounidense que haya dicho que el Islam es malvado,
le será difícil hacerlo. Ok.
Así que es algo muy difícil hacer que las personas amplíen su imaginación moral
hasta un lugar al cual naturalmente no llega.
Pero creo que vale la pena intentarlo,
porque nos ayuda a comprender,
y si uno quiere reducir el número de personas que queman banderas,
entender qué los lleva a hacerlo será de ayuda.
Creo que es un buen ejercicio moral.
Y de nuevo aquí es donde entran los líderes religiosos,
porque los líderes religiosos son hábiles en reformular temas
para sacar provecho de los centros emocionales del cerebro
y hacer que las personas modifiquen su consciencia y reformulen su manera de pensar
Quiero decir que los líderes religiosos están en el negocio de la inspiración.
Actualmente esa es su principal vocación,
hacer que las personas de todo el mundo mejoren en la ampliación de su imaginación moral
y comprendan que en muchos sentidos todos van en el mismo barco.
Voy a resumir cómo lucen las cosas, al menos desde esta perspectiva secular,
en lo que concierne a la compasión y la regla de oro,
diciendo que es una buena noticia que la compasión y la regla de oro
estén en cierto sentido incorporadas en la naturaleza humana.
Pero es desafortunado que tiendan a manifestarse selectivamente.
Y nos tomará un gran trabajo cambiarlo.
Pero nunca nadie dijo que hacer el trabajo de Dios sería sencillo. Gracias.
(Aplausos)